نداء امام عاجل لاتخاذ اجراءات لحمايه
الاطفال الاكثر ضعفا 15 بلدا متضررا بشده
من ازمه غذاء وتغذيه غير مسبوقه ابرز تلك
الدول هي افغانستان و تشاد واثيوبيا
وكينيا ومالي والنيجر ونيجيريا والصومال
وجنوب السودان والسودان واليمن
[موسيقى]
استمرار الصراع والتغيرات المناخيه
وتداعيات جائعه كورونا مع ارتفاع تكاليف
المعيشه تجعل اعدادا متزايده من الاطفال
يعانون من سوء التغذيه الحاد فاكثر من 30
مليون طفل في الدول 15 يعانون من سوء
التغذيه الحاد بينما يعاني ثمانيه ملايين
منها هؤلاء الاطفال من الهزل الشديد وهو
اكثر اشكال نقص التغذيه في التكن هذا عدا
عن صعوبه الوصول الى الخدمات الصحيه
والتغذيه وغيرها من الخدمات المنقذه
للحياه من المرشح ان يتدهور هذا الوضع
اكثر في عام 2023 يجب ان نضمن توفر النظم
الغذائيه الصحيه والقدره على تحمل
تكاليفها وامكانيه وصولها الى الاطفال
الصغار والفتيات والنساء الحوامل
والمرضعات الذات الازمات المتتاليه التي
تسبب بالهلال لملايين الاطفال وجعلت من
الصعب عليهم الوصول الى الخدمات اسيه
الهزال مؤلم للاطفال وفي الحالات الشديده
قد يؤدي الى الوفاه او الاضرار الدائم
بنمو الاطفال وتطورهم
هذا وتواصل الوكالات الحث على زياده
الاستثمار لدعم جهودها لتلبيه الاحتياجات
غير المسبوقه لهذه الازمه المتناميه وتجنب
الخسائر الماساويه في ارواح الاطفال قبل
فوات الاوان رشا خياط العربيه